d'abord je crois qu'il faut prendre
cette nouvelle pour ce qu'elle est c'est
un ancien premier ministre donc une
personnalité éminente qui juge que la
démarche des manuels macro et celle que
nous poursuivons est donc la bonne pour
la france donc moi j'en prends acte avec
satisfaction ensuite pour le reste s'il
souhaite être candidat aux législatives
et singulièrement investi par la
république en marche
eh bien il faut qu'il matérialise sa
candidature que la commission nationale
d'investiture que préside jean paul
delevoye s'en saisissent et jeudi avant
midi
vous avez à vous d'avoir également un
souhait un voeu est ce que vous le
souhaitez voir investie est ce que vous
me dire oui ou non écoutez vous savez
tout ça n'est pas le fait d'une ou autre
une autre personnalité c'est un ensemble
nous avons posé des critères nous
voulons plus de 50% qui attendait le
candidat guy proviennent de la société
civile respecter la parité le pluralisme
et c'est alors si la démarche de manuel
valls trouve sa place dans cet ensemble
de critères
je ne vois pas a priori d'inconvénient
mais pas d'inconvénients mais vous y
mettez des cibles même comme si ça
n'était pas automatique vous l'avez dit
un ancien premier ministre et rien n'est
automatique moi j'ai déposé ma
candidature je ne suis pas encore
investi à l'heure qu'il est vous n'êtes
pas encore mais sur le fond manuel valls
est tout à fait ma compagne est
compatible vous êtes d'accord il a
appelé à voter pour lui oui non je crois
qu'il faut il faut examiner les ses
motivations les termes les termes de sa
candidature voilà faire ce que l'on fait
beaucoup